the last topic we're going to discuss is
is a pretty hot topic today
um and it's arisen in the last few years
and it's known
goes by the name of double descent
and
just to set the stage so with neural
networks it seems that it's better to
have too many hidden units than too few
likewise more hidden layers seem better
than few
running stochastic gradient descent
until zero training error often gives
good out of sample error
in fact in many of these networks like
image where the signal to noise ratio is
high that's what's done they just run
all the way till you get zero training
error and number of parameters in these
networks are enormous
increasing the number of units or layers
and again training till zero errors
sometimes give even better out of sample
error so all this sort of
lays out the fact that it seems like
neural networks are reluctant to overfit
and you could put as many parameters as
you like in the model
so what happened to overfitting then the
usual variance by a bias variance
trade-off
and so this is
set of a firestorm of papers and
research
and one of the original papers is is
referenced here and the title is
reconcile in modern machine learning and
the bias variance tradeoff
basically the message is from these
papers in this research is that the bias
fairness tradeoff is all wrong in modern
settings so we've had people talk about
both of our books and the u-shaped
error curve for test error and saying
it's wrong that's that that doesn't
apply to neural networks
let's see
so
rob and i and and and others have worked
on this and uh
and that's why we've added a section in
the book
on doubles ascent double descent because
many people have now heard of it and we
want to give our point of view
and to do that we're going to do a
little simulation which is often
simulations are helpful for
understanding phenomenon so this is very
simple we have we're going to generate
data from a sine curve
um and the feature x is going to be
uniformly distributed on -5 to 5
and the error is going to be gaussian
with standard deviation 0.3 so you can
do the simulation yourself
we have a small training set of size 20
and we have a very large test set and by
the way if you do a simulation there's
no value in having a small test set make
it really large you want to find out
exactly
what the test area is so we're going to
fit a natural spline to the data
and if if you've forgotten about natural
splines these are in sections 7.4 of the
book
and it's a way of fitting a flexible
function
and there's lectures as well on natural
splines in the series
and we're going to fit with d degrees of
freedom
so it's going to be that what that means
is you're going to
be fitting a linear regression onto d
basis functions so your prediction's
going to be of the form
a linear combination of these
these basis functions with d parameters
and what we're going to change is d
so we're going to enrich this basis by
increasing d and see what happens so
when d is 20 you're going to have
exactly the same number of features as
you've got training observations right
and
because these basis functions are all
different you're going to fit the
training data exactly
and and all the residuals are going to
equal to zero
but now we're going to even go further
we're going to let d get bigger than 20.
so we need to say what we're going to do
there well
what we do is
when d is bigger than 20 you can still
get zero residual solutions but they're
not going to be unique at exactly 20
you'll get a single solution but when d
is bigger than 20 there's infinitely
many solutions with zero residual so
you've got to pick amongst them
so among the zero residual solutions
we'll pick the one with what's known as
minimum norm
i.e the zero residual solution with the
smallest value of sum of squares of beta
j squared
and we'll see why that
how that plays a role
and we'll also explain in a little while
why we set up this particular simulation
in this kind
so here's a result and this shows the
double descent curve
so in this picture we show
on the horizontal axis the degrees of
freedom or d
as we add
basis functions
the vertical axis we show that the arrow
the test error is in blue and the
training error is in orange so sure
enough you can see the training error
that's over the 20 observations
as d increases it drops and drops and
drops and at d equals 20 it hits zero
and then of course thereafter it's zero
and the degrees of freedom we shown on
the log scale and so you can see things
get compressed up here
the test error is what is interesting
here the test error
initially drops
and then starts increasing as we start
overfitting the training data
and this part shows the usual bias
variance tradeoff right
initially
error is high because of bias drops down
and then error starts increasing because
of variance and literally shoots through
the ceiling here
but then something interesting happens
the error starts decreasing again and so
this is the double descent
and it starts decreasing reaches a
minimum and then it seems like it starts
increasing again
so what happens
as d increases above 20
is
the sum of squares of the coefficients
even though they're more coefficients
the sum of squares decreases
because we have more opportunities to
fit the data exactly
and so we can find a configuration of
betas
that have a smaller sum of squares
so let's say we go from d's 25 to d is
40.
right
one candidate is the solution we got at
d equals
25
but we've got lots of other candidates
because we've got 40 and we could set
the remaining ones to zero so that's a
candidate so we can only do better in if
we're trying to minimize the sum of
squares of the betas having more
betas to do it and it turns out that
what that does is
by making the sum of squares of the beta
small that means all the betas are
getting smaller
um we're going to have
less wiggly solutions they're getting
smaller i guess they're being spread out
over more functions right and yeah
spread out over more functions
and so this picture shows what's
happening
so here's eight degrees of freedom which
let's see eight degrees of freedom
that's around here that's a pretty good
solution that's about as as good as we
get right
and you can see it's getting a nice
approximating solution
here's 20 degrees of freedom
this is the one
you know so what we show in here is the
true sine wave the actual data points 20
data points
and we're showing the fitted curve
and we're showing the footed curve
everywhere
so 20 of course a fitted curve
has to go through every data point which
it does the observed data points
but what you see is
in order to do that with exactly 20
degrees of freedom it has to really
stretch itself and the function goes
shooting off in all different places
elsewhere because the loss is only
concerned with the training data
right so it really has to stretch itself
to to to fit the data exactly
but when you go to 42 degrees of freedom
for example
which is where we achieve the minimum
to the right of the the 20 point
you can see the function's much better
behave these departures it's a much
smoother function still making little
jumps in that but nothing nearly as
severe as that
and that's because all these d's are
smaller
and likewise you go up to 80 not too
much as has changed over there okay
so that's an explanation for what's
going on in in this little example
so here's some facts
so in a wide linear model in other words
p is much bigger than n
and you fit by least squares using
stochastic gradient descent with a small
step size
and you keep on going
that leads to a minimum norm residual
solution so this ties stochastic
gradient descent
and and going all the way to the
solution to the minimum zero residual
solution
it actually gets
the minimum norm solution
right with a minimum sum of squares of
the betas
and stochastic gradient descents used in
the neural network so by analogy
by training slowly to zero residual you
get in a more regularized solution
another way of talking about this is
stochastic gradient flow i.e the entire
path of stochastic gradient descent
solutions is somewhat similar to the
ridge path
so the ridge path is the sequence of
solutions you get when you slowly vary
the ridge regularization parameter
that's called the ridge path of
solutions
and this the stochastic
gradient flow is a sequence of solutions
you get as you go down gradient descent
they quite similar not exactly but quite
so by analogy deep and white neural
networks fit by stochastic gradient
descent down to zero training error
often give good solutions that
generalize well
and in particular cases with high signal
to noise ratio eg image recognition are
less prone to overfitting the zero error
solutions in in and is mostly a signal
the zero error solution is mostly a
signal
okay so that's that's
uh that little discussion on on
on double descent
so we'll end up this just talking a bit
about software this wonderful software
available for neural networks and and
deep learning
so tensorflow from google and pytorch
from facebook and and both are python
packages
so in the chapter 10 lab we demonstrate
tensorflow and keras package in r which
interface to pi to the python versions
of these packages
and so you can see the the text book and
online resources for for our markdown
and jupyter notebooks for these and all
the labs in the second edition of the
book
and there's a torch package in r which
is
which is available as well
and it
implements the pie torch
version of a dialect for fit in neural
networks
and the chapter 10 lab will be available
in the in this dialect as well so if you
watch the resource page at
www.statlearning.com